as he read the Bible I read because they  talked about forgiveness they said don't  look at this spec in your brothers I  look at the point in your own eye you  got to ask for forgiveness and he never  asked for forgiveness and moved on he's  still talking about the past we don't  want to live in the past y'all can I  tell you this here aren't you Barker  when he would be on the air today would  it now and  he's in love Archer bunker did you not  like Archer Parker Kobe called The  Senator were not it wouldn't be on air  because he's still living in the past  you gotta I don't know what he's talking  about  it wouldn't be on Archie Bunker went off  the air in 1983 and the guy who played  Archie Bunker died more than 20 years  ago  it's just this this is not about which  candidate's tax policy do we prefer okay  this is absurd